señor presidente gracias
estuve en síria por 63 días retenido
creo que hablo por a
todos detenidos y rehenes estoy bastante
agradecido por hora de regresar a casa
me salvó gracias por la invitación y la
oportunidad de estar aquí
particularmente el pastor bryant ha sido
de gran ayuda a mi familia gracias por
promocionarlo a él gracias por estar
aquí
te trajimos de vuelta los trajimos a
todos de vuelta y estamos trabajando
para atraer a otros más mi nombre es
michael y una vez más es un honor estar
aquí un honor conocerlo en persona
básicamente lo que sucedió conmigo fue
que trabaje a irán y hubo una trampa y
estuve detenido pase por mucho en el
sistema de justicia iraní
pero lo que usted hizo puede lograr
sacarme de allá en un tiempo récord fue
increíble muchas gracias
mi nombre es yo soy mi esposa mis
tuvimos rehenes en venezuela por 2 años
y usted nos ayuda a salir de allá
y fue un gran honor poder conocerlo
cuando regresábamos recordamos que mucha
gente me preguntó cómo era conoce al
presidente trozo he estado impresionada
me habían liberado después de dos años y
estaba saludando al presidente en la
oficina así que es bueno estar de vuelta
haya sido increíble volver y ayudar a la
gente que ha experimentado lo mismo
hemos empezado a una familia y nosotros
pudimos hacer algo por estados y creo
que por varios estadounidenses fue un
periodo bastante hostil
apreciamos bastante a todos los que
trabajaron con nosotros para que
lograron lograrán volver
así que saludos a todos en youtube
porque son grandes personas
felicitaciones muchas gracias
estuve limpia no iba a ir a india iba de
india nepal donde trabajan los últimos
18 años pero nombre de mi familia y de
mi quiero agradecer al presidente trump
por traernos de vuelta el momento más
oscuro de todo nuestro tiempo juntos
llegó su carta
nos dio paz y esperanza y mientras más
gente se vea involucrada al embajador en
india todo nos llenó de esperanza
estudiar los últimos cuatro meses así
que lo logramos volver planeaban tenerme
de 3 a 5 años los cargos eran de 3 a 5
años y hacer aclaró luego se inventaron
nuevos cargos que son 7 años usted
respondió bastante a nuestra
requerimiento lo apreciamos gracias a
ustedes por estar con nosotros queremos
otras más personas de vuelta y volverán
de regreso pronto
muchas gracias grandes historias